you know therapist is a funny word
because i see friendship and love as
therapy i mean so therapist broadly
defined as just friendship as a friend
so like therapists has a very kind of
clinical sense to it but what is human
connection
you're like uh
not to get all camus and dostoyevsky on
you but you know life is suffering and
we draw
we
seek connection with other humans as we
desperately try to make sense of this
world
in the deep overwhelming loneliness that
we feel
inside
so i think connection has to do with
understanding
and i think that almost like a lack of
understanding causes suffering if you
speak with someone and you
do you feel ignored that actually causes
pain if you are feeling deeply
understood that actually
they they might not even tell you what
to do in life but like a pure
understanding or just being heard
understanding is a kind of
that's a lot you know just being heard
feel like you're being heard
like somehow
that's uh alleviation temporarily of the
loneliness
that if somebody
knows you're here
with their body language with the way
they are or the way they look at you
with the way they talk
you feel less alone for a brief moment
yeah very much agree so i thought in the
past about the
somewhat similar question to yours which
is what is love
uh rather what is connection yes and
and obviously i think about these things
from ai perspective what would it mean
um
so i said that the
you know intelligence has to do with
some compression which is more or less
like i can say almost understanding of
what is going around it seems to me that
other aspect is there seem to be reward
functions and you can have a
you know reward for
food for maybe human connection for
let's say warmth
uh
sex and so on
and um
and it turns out that the various people
might be optimizing slightly different
reward functions they essentially might
care about different things
and
in case of
love at least the love between two
people you can say that the
you know boundary between people
dissolves to such extent that they end
up optimizing each other reward
functions
yeah
oh that's interesting um
celebrate the success of each other yeah
in some sense i would say love means
helping others to optimize their reward
functions not your reward functions not
the things that you think are important
but the things that the person cares
about
you
try to help them to optimize it
so love is uh if you think of two reward
functions you just it's a condition yeah
you combine them together yeah pretty
much maybe like with a weight and it
depends like the dynamic of the
relationship yeah i mean you could
imagine that if you are fully uh
optimizing someone's reward function
without yours then yeah then maybe are
creating code dependency or something
like that yeah
i'm not sure what's the appropriate
weight but the interesting thing is i
even i even think that the
individual person uh
we ourselves we are actually
less of a
unified insight so for instance if you
look at the donut on the one level you
might think oh this like it looks tasty
i would like to eat it on another level
you might tell yourself i shouldn't be
doing it because
i want to gain muscles so and you know
you might do it regardless kind of
against yourself so it seems that even
within ourselves they're almost like a
kind of intertwined personas
and
i believe that the self-love
means that
the love between all these persons which
also means being able to
love
yourself when we are angry or stressed
or so combining all those reward
functions of the different selves you
have yeah and accepting that they are
there okay you know often people they
have a negative self-talk or they say i
don't like when i'm angry and like i try
to imagine
try to imagine
if there would be
like a
small baby alex like a five years old
who's
angry and then you're like you shouldn't
be angry like stop being angry yeah but
like instead actually on the legs to
come over give him a hug and he's like i
say it's fine okay you can't be angry as
long as you want yeah then he would stop
or or maybe not or maybe not but you
cannot expect it even
you